القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه البرازيليه
البرازيليه اذا نتابع هذه الصور ونذكر
بانه همم تم اقتحام القصر والعديد من
مباني الوزارات والكونجرس كذلك في
برازيليا من قبل الانصار رئيس البرازيل
السابق اليمني ياير بون سونارو مقابل او
بعد ايام على همم تنصيب له لادا سيلفا
اليسار مجددا في حكم البرازيل اذا نشاهد
هذه الصور لمكتب
الرئيس البرازيلي همم السابق طبعا
الحليب ولكن الاقتحام هو من مناصري الرئيس
البرازيلي السابق اذا نشاهد تحطيم طاهر
للغرف الطاولات
واخر المعلومات تقول بانه متواجد فيه ساو
باولو
وكنا نذكر يوم التنصيب بانه كان هناك
تهديدات كثيره من قبل مناصرين الذي توجه
الى الولايات المتحده لكي يتفادي تسلم
والتسليم بين بينه وبين لولا سيلفا طبعا
يعني نتحدث عن
ولايتين كان همم فيهما الاقتصاد البرازيلي
هشام جدا خاصه
وتضخم همم يعني يبدو مع رغم عوده الاولى
بانه همم تحديات ستبقى همم على ما كانت
عليه رغم كل وعوده صحيح اذا نتابع اي صور
جديده في حال ورودها